[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN KEMLER: Good
afternoon, everybody.
My name is Brian Kemler.
I'm a product manager, and I
work on Android accessibility.
RICARDO GARCIA: Hi,
and I'm Ricardo Garcia,
a software engineer in the
audio framework team in Android.
BRIAN KEMLER: How's
everybody's last day of I/O?
Last session, woo!
You made it, through.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
It was a great
I/O. Today we have
a lot of really exciting
things to talk about,
primarily geared for developers.
We're going to be talking about
a new sound enhanced future
in Android P called
Sound Amplifier.
We're going to be doing a
little bit of a live demo
to show how we can improve the
sound in any type of situation
for users, and how you can
do the same as a developer.
We're going to go and do a deep
dive into the inner workings
of Sound Amplifier and the
dynamics processing effect
upon which it's built,
live with code examples.
That's going to be really cool.
Let's dive right in.
Listening is difficult,
even in an empty field
with a massive set of ears.
But the everyday reality
is we live, work,
and play with an increasing
amount of environmental noise.
In fact, unwanted sound
is one of the most common
environmental problems.
It's not only annoying,
but it prevents us
from understanding our friends,
colleagues, and loved ones.
No matter how well
we can hear, most of
us can relate to the following
acoustically challenging
situations--
trying to understand your
date in a loud restaurant
or a loud bar, trying to
listen to a caller in a really
loud airport lounge,
trying to listen
to a speaker who's talking
way too softly, like me now.
One could think of
environmental noise
as a form of
situational disability.
But what if you could
hear better using just
your smartphone so
you'd never miss
a word in the conversation?
Now you can, because today we're
introducing Sound Amplifier.
What is Sound Amplifier?
Sound Amplifier is a new
accessibility service
that helps users focus on
real world conversations using
only your Android smartphone
and a set of headphones.
Users can tune to hundreds
of personalized levels
to optimize their
listening experience
to the current environment.
Its two sliders for loudness
and tuning dynamically
adjust just over 100 audio
presets in the background.
These settings can be applied
independently to each ear.
Adjusting them improves
the sound quality
in an array of situations,
including the following--
enhancing sound in loud,
dissonant, or otherwise
acoustically
challenging situations,
increasing the volume of
somebody who speaks too softly,
turning up the TV
volume to one that's
acceptable to
everybody in the room
without blasting everybody else.
So now I'm going to go in and
talk a little bit about how
we built it, the APIs and the
effect upon which it was built,
and I'll do some demos.
Sound Amplifier is based
on Android P's new dynamics
processing effect.
The effect is a four-stage
signal processing architecture,
and I'm going to walk
you through each stage,
and then Ricardo's going
to come in a little bit
and really deep dive into
this, and show the developers
in the audience exactly
how they can adapt this
to their applications.
So first, stage one.
Stage one is pre-equalization.
You can think of
pre-equalization
as an equalizer that
you can programmatically
adjust any audio frequency.
Think bass, mid-range, treble--
the entire audio spectrum.
Stage two is a
multiband compressor.
The multiband compressor
is the heart and soul
of the dynamics processing
effect, because what it does
is really unique.
It can simultaneously adjust
down really loud or irritating
sounds- don't worry,
I won't make any--
and adjust up sounds
that are too soft.
It could do all of
this without changing
the characteristics of
the underlying audio
that you put into the system.
The third stage is also an
equalization [INAUDIBLE]..
Post-equalization
allows you to fine tune
the output from the original NBC
and the original pre-equalizer.
And lastly is the limiter.
What the limiter does
is protects users
from additional gain
or additional volume
above a certain
developer-designated threshold
so that there are
no loud, jarring,
or uncomfortable noises.
So now I'm going to switch
over and do a little demo.
So I'm going to play a very
typical Google microkitchen,
water cooler-type of break
where there's a loud espresso
maker in the background.
And I'm in this.
I star in this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Do you really?
Wow.
- [INAUDIBLE]
BRIAN KEMLER: So you
can hear the sound is--
you can't really hear
the conversation.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- So you could've escaped
from Alcatraz if you had to.
- I swam far enough to
escape from Alcatraz.
- Did you really?
Wow.
You should have
swum to Alcatraz.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRIAN KEMLER: So
I can dynamically
adjust this and start to
hear the conversation.
Remember, this is customizable
or tunable for every user.
Doing this again--
I get to star again.
I'm really not this into myself.
Here's me talking, kind of
rehearsing this talk right now.
And I'm speaking
too quietly, so this
will be another example of
how I can adjust the sound so
that I can hear it better.
The other thing that I
also forgot to mention
was you use this
with your headphones,
so you can think of what's in
the video as what you would
be hearing in your headphones.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So listening is
difficult, even
under the best circumstances,
in a quiet field
with no background noise
and a large set of ears.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRIAN KEMLER: So you
can hear the boost.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- But in noisy conditions,
the everyday reality
is that we work, play, and
live with an increasing
amount of environmental noise,
so listening is difficult.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRIAN KEMLER: So it's
very easy to fine tune
any acoustic situation to the
environment, to your ears,
and so forth.
And Ricardo's going to deep dive
in and talk a little bit more
about the dynamics
processing effect,
and how developers can
start using this today.
RICARDO GARCIA:
Thank you, Brian.
BRIAN KEMLER: Off
to you, Ricardo.
RICARDO GARCIA: Thank you.
Well, now we saw the demos
and we saw the Sound Amplifier
actually working in real life.
So we are going
to go down and see
how the Sound Amplifier
actually works,
and what is the magic behind it.
So for that, I want to introduce
to you the hearing threshold.
I'm going to be on this
slide for a second.
I'm going to explain
to you what is here.
And here, we are seeing what is
the average hearing threshold
for the average human.
The hearing
threshold is actually
how much energy we
need to have to be
able to listen to the sound.
So in this plot, we can
see from left to right,
from low frequency
to high frequencies,
from 20 hertz to 20 kilohertz.
And in the vertical axis,
we can see the amplitude.
We see how much energy
we actually will
need to hear of the sounds.
So because this is the
threshold of hearing in quiet,
this [INAUDIBLE]
telling that anything
that is below that threshold
will not be heard by people.
So for example, if we go and
we look into the 4,000 hertz,
we see that the threshold
is lower in there.
That means that we
need less energy.
The sounds can be fainter,
they can be softer,
and we will hear them.
But if we have a sound that
is about the same level in
around, I don't
know, 100 hertz, you
will not be able to hear that.
So this is important
because many companies
use these curves, these kind
of hearing threshold curves
to design their equipment.
When you are designing, I
don't know, MP3 or CD players,
these curves are present.
Or if you are tuning a
headset, speakers, microphones,
all of these curves are
really important to know
what people will actually hear
and what they are sensitive to.
But these curves can shift.
So we can have hearing
threshold shifts
due to many
circumstances-- let's say,
the noise in the environment.
A minute ago, we had
the AC blasting in here
and there was a threshold shift.
We needed to have sounds
that were way louder
over that threshold to be able
to listen to hear the sounds.
When the AC turned
off a minute ago,
as well, we can speak
softer and we hear that.
Our threshold shifted
down at that moment.
So a threshold shift
is a region that
will need more energy for you
to be able to notice that.
We have other shifts.
We can have shifts that
are not as broadband,
not all over the spectrum.
On the previous one, we can have
shifts that are more localized.
This blue curve in here
is showing us a shift
that is around 500 hertz--
really, really, really high.
There is some noise or
some obstruction there
that is not going to
allow you to hear things
very well around 500 hertz.
This shift could be permanent--
all your life you're going
to have that shift-- or it
could be temporary.
As Brian mentioned, it could
be a temporary situation
or disability.
That means that for
that period of time,
you are not going to
be able to hear things
around those frequencies because
either your headphones are not
working well, you are
in a noisy environment,
your ears are not working
well at that moment.
Sounds that are below
that threshold, that
shifted threshold, you are not
going to be able to hear that,
and that's the important
take-away from this.
If it's below the threshold,
you cannot hear it.
So what happens when we
have a sound of interest?
Let's say that you are
listening to music,
or someone is speaking, or
some sound that interests you.
So in the plot I just put a blob
that's a green blob in there,
and it's a broadband sound.
It has a lot of frequencies
and it has energy
all over the place.
But if you notice,
again, around 500 hertz,
a lot of the energy that
is below the threshold,
the shifted threshold, the
blue one, is going to be lost.
When you have a sound
of interest that
is below the threshold,
the shifted threshold,
it's going to be
difficult to be heard,
or the intelligibility
is really bad.
You cannot understand the sound.
So this is the
question that everybody
is asking-- how can Sound
Amplifier help us right now?
So I'm glad that you asked.
Sound Amplifier is
going to take the sounds
and is going to
actually boost them
where you need them the most.
If we look again in the range
from 500 hertz to 1 kilohertz,
we took the sounds, and in
this new, processed sound,
we took the sounds that were
really soft, that they didn't
have that much energy,
and we boosted them
all the way over the
shifted threshold,
so now we can hear those.
But-- very important-- we took
the sounds the were really
loud, we moved them up,
but not too much up,
so the loud sounds get
louder, but not too loud.
So if you see the
process that happened,
it was not uniform
all over the spectrum.
It was shifting things and
trying to accommodate them
over our shifted threshold.
So it was doing very
intelligent boost in there.
All of this processing is done
by the new dynamics processing
effect that we
introduced in Android P.
And I'm going to talk more.
I'm going to show
[INAUDIBLE] in a minute.
I promise.
So the dynamics processing
effect, as Brian mentioned,
is the new processing
effect that we have.
It has four stages--
the pre-EQ,
multiband compressor,
post-EQ, and limiter.
And when we are
using this effect,
we have two big questions
that we need to answer,
especially for our
Sound Amplifier.
First is what kind of
processing do we actually
want to hear sounds?
To be able to, depending
of the needs that we have--
if we're in a loud environment,
or we are in a bad connection,
or we are in an airport--
what kind of
processing do we need
to make things above the
shifted threshold that we have?
And the second is how
users can actually
go and move and find
the right parameters
that they need for you.
So we have two big
questions to answer.
The first one, for
the processing,
what kind of
processing we want, we
did what Google
is really good at.
We took a lot of data and we
started crunching that data.
So we took data from
hearing thresholds
from regular and
hearing-impaired users,
so actually how people hear,
how their ears respond,
and we put them in there.
We took threshold shifts from
different environment places
and different
environment noises.
We went to airports,
restaurants,
and places where we have
noise obstructions--
things that are going to shift
our threshold of hearing--
and we also put
them in the blender.
And we went and tried to get
the audio content that people
actually want to hear--
conversations, movies,
music, live concerts,
lectures-- and we managed
to pull all of this
together and come up with a
set of recipes, of parameters,
that would be good
for processing
the sound in many situations.
When you do that, you
end up with, I will say,
a multi-dimensional space,
a bunch of solutions,
that are pretty
much very complex
parameters that you want to tell
the dynamics effects processor,
oh, for this
situation, this will
be good to shift the sound.
For this situation,
it will be that.
But that's unmanageable.
If you want to tell
the users, well,
start moving
parameters like this,
there will be
hundreds of parameters
and it will be very
difficult for the users
to make something
good with this.
So we took a
further step and did
some dimensionality reduction.
Took all of those recipes,
multi-dimensional space,
and flattened them out and
plotted them in two dimensions.
And here, in the
plot on the right,
you can see that we
see each one of those
is kind of a formula
or a processing recipe
that we want to feed
the dynamics processing
effect to change the sound.
And with the
dimensionality reduction,
we found two major axes--
the tone and the boost.
So this solves the second
question that we have,
how the users are
going to navigate this.
Well, they don't need to
know all the parameters
that we need, we just
give them two sliders--
the two sliders that we
just saw on the demo.
And by moving
those sliders, they
are actually doing a
very intelligent mapping
and going and moving
hundreds of parameters
that are moving for
each channel in there.
When the user goes and
iterates using these sliders,
they are actually going
through a bunch of recipes,
a bunch of processings,
and they come
find the one that suits
them the best at that moment
for that user in that location.
And that's what we wanted to do.
So that was kind of
like a bird's eye view
of how the Sound
Amplifier works.
Now we are going to go deeper
and start talking about code.
What can you do with the
dynamics processing effects?
So you can find the
dynamics processing effect
in [INAUDIBLE] library in the
Android media audio effects--
dynamics processing.
So let's start talking
about use cases.
So when can you use a
dynamics processing effect?
The first use case
we saw at length,
you can do a Sound Amplifier.
So if you go today,
because this is now
available in the Android
P developer preview,
you can go tonight--
I'm sure that everybody is
going to skip the party--
and go and create your
own Sound Amplifier.
So with the Sound Amplifier,
with the dynamics processing
effect, we are expecting
people to create
their own Sound Amplifiers
or create their own solutions
to be able to hear
better, to listen better.
Another example, another
[INAUDIBLE] that can happen
is when you have a
device, an Android device,
and you want to tune the
speakers or the headphones.
Many companies have software
that will equalize or do
something to the headphones
to make them sound flatter,
better, to have more
bass-- something you want.
Now, with this
effect, it will be
easy for you and for
your clients to do that.
Another application that
is really interesting
is the TV midnight mode.
If you are watching TV,
2:00 AM, you cannot sleep,
but if you start
watching a movie,
and sometimes someone is
whispering in the movie,
just saying something really
quiet, and immediately, bam,
music comes in there,
something really loud,
you woke up everybody
in the house.
With the dynamics
processing effect,
you can actually have
something that they whisper--
the very soft parts of the movie
can be raised up, but the very
loud music or
gunshots or whatever
is happening in the
movie, it can bring down,
and everything is
going to work on a more
level of sound in there,
[INAUDIBLE] sound.
Another example can
be for media players.
You are doing your
own media player
and you want to actually do
some loudness maximization
or mastering.
You want to listen to classical
music in your media player
and you are in a train.
You would like to
have the control
to be able to, again, squeeze
the loud sounds on bring up
the soft sounds so
everything is working well
for the dynamic range
that you have in there.
Now I'm going to talk a
little bit about architecture,
and I promise code
is coming, but I
want to show the architecture.
We are giving you a lot
of power with this effect.
So the architecture
that we showed before,
we were kind of lying.
It's not as simple.
It's a little bit more complex.
The architecture-- yes,
we have four stages.
We have a pre-EQ, multiband
compressor, post-EQ,
and limiter, but we can
do more things in there.
Inside of each one
of those stages,
we have a lot of parameters
that you can control.
We have the bands, and in the
pre-EQ, multiband compressor,
and post-EQ, we can have
as many bands as you want,
and you can control
each one of those bands
and the parameters
in those bands.
The limiter is a
single-band limiter,
but you can also control that.
All of these comes
into a channel.
We have defined the
channel as let's say
you have a stereo signal.
Stereo signal has two
channels, left and right,
so we are going to have
channel 0 and channel 1,
and you can control all
of those independently,
or you can have
many more channels.
Let's say that you
have a 5.1 signal.
You actually have six
channels that you can control,
and you can index all of
those channels and say,
I want to change the
multiband controller
band number 3 in the channel
2, and I want to change this.
We are giving you an API
to do all of those things.
One thing that I want you
to notice is the limiters.
The limiters are
linked limiters.
I'm going to talk
more about that,
but it's important
when you are talking
about [INAUDIBLE] channel to be
able to change all the limiters
kind of at once if you need to.
So now, finally, code.
Yes.
We promised code,
we have some code.
So this is an instantiation
example of the dynamics
processing effect.
For this, we decided, because we
have so many parameters and so
many things that
can be configured,
to have a config builder.
So you create a config
builder, and then we
are actually going to
instantiate the effect.
First, with the config
builder in this example,
we can have some parameters,
like the variant,
the number of channels--
I'm going to talk more
about that in a second.
Then we can enable or disable
each one of the stages.
In this example, we have all
the stages enabled-- yes,
we want to use pre-EQ,
multiband compressor, post-EQ,
and limiter--
and the number of bands.
We can say how many bands
we want per stage type.
So all the pre-EQs
can have, let's say,
8 bands, the multiband
compressors 10 bands,
and they post-EQ 13 bands.
The only limitation is,
like, the stage type needs
to have the same
number of bands,
but then you can choose any
number of bands that you want.
We have some extra
parameters, as I mentioned--
the variant and the number of
channels and the set prefered
frame duration--
that you can set in
the config builder.
Then in the last
line, we are actually
creating a configuration.
We are saying build, and we
have a configuration object.
Then I don't want to use
the configuration directly.
Sometimes I want to finish
the architecture of my effect
and go and change the
default parameters.
So in this example,
I'm getting a channel,
I'm getting a channel object in
the first line from the config,
and I'm saying, from channel
number 0, in this case,
get the multiband compressor.
We have the multiband
compressor stage.
And then I iterate
through the eight bands
that I have in my
multiband compressor,
and I went and changed the
parameters in each one of them.
This is an example
for I/O. I'm sure
that in real-world applications,
you can go and do more things.
But you see that we can go
and set each one of the things
that we want--
that release, the
attack, the ratio
of the threshold--
the way that you
want for each one of the bands.
And finally, we
go and instantiate
my dynamics processing effect,
and you can instantiate it
with the config
file that we just
created and the session ID.
That's where you attach
this effect to whatever
the media player or the audio
track of interest for you.
And then you kind of start
just going in your program
and controlling everything.
Instead of going on the API and
just showing the [INAUDIBLE],,
I'm going to go a little bit
more meta, more conceptual,
to show this in
graphics a little bit.
So in the configuration, or
when we are running real time,
we can have access to
channels that I just show you.
And we have many channels.
So the channel object,
and we can index
the channel by index numbers.
So 0, 1, 2, 3-- we
can get the channel.
Each channel object
actually has some parameters
like the input gain that you can
go and change on the channel.
Or you have the stages.
You can access the [? pre-q ?]
multiband compressor,
[? post-q, ?] or limiter.
And let's say at this
moment, in the EQ,
you can actually grab the EQ.
Both EQs look exactly the
same from the API level,
from the API viewpoint.
And you can go and change
the parameters on the EQ
or change the parameters in
each one of the bands there.
Sorry, it's going very deeper.
So we can go from
band to the EQ,
from channel and then the
collection of channels.
So we have access to
all the granularities
that we want there.
The same thing for the
multiband compressor.
We can access the
multiband compressor
on the side of the channel
and then access the parameters
that we have in each
one of the bands.
And lastly, the limiter.
We don't have bands in the
limiter, only the parameters
there.
And we can access that.
So now I'm going to
dive a little bit more
on each stage type and what
are the accessors that we have,
the setters and getters
that we have there?
First, the equalizer.
I think that most people are
familiar with the equalizer,
what an equalizer does.
But if, not very quickly--
with an equalizer, we are going
to specify different frequency
bands.
We are going to
have bands from 0
to 500 hertz, 500 to
3,000, 3,000 to 7,000.
And we are going to change the
energy, the level or the gain
that we have in each
one of those bands.
In here, we can set the
bands any way that we want.
So we can have many bands,
and we can have any color
frequencies that we want.
And this graph is
kind of misleading,
because all of the bands
have the same width.
That's not true.
You can do any
width that you want.
And once that you set
up the bands, you can go
and, with the accessors
that we have here,
we can get the gain--
what is the current gain--
or we can set the gain.
And we can change all of
this, also, real time.
We are going to--
then, the multiband compressor.
So first a disclaimer.
Someone was pointing
out you are only
showing one band in the
multiband compressor.
And yes, I'm showing
one band, but this
is easy to show what the
multiband compressor does.
As Brian mentioned
and we have mentioned,
when you have a compressor,
a multiband compressor,
the main goal is to take
sounds that are really loud
and make them softer, and
sounds that are very soft
and make them louder.
The way that we have
here represented,
we have the same
sentence in the before.
We have the sentence
that is loud, medium,
and soft in the top.
And after we apply
the processing
of the multiband compressor, is
going to look like the after.
That is, the loud sound
is a little bit softer.
The medium one stays medium.
And the soft one goes very loud.
The way that a multiband
compressor works,
or the parameters work-- bear
with me for a second for this
graphic--
is we have the inputs, what
is the level of the signal
in the horizontal axis.
And the numbers are
from minus 100 to 10.
The lower the
number, like minus 50
is way softer than maybe
minus 10, for example.
So minus 10 will be
louder, a louder sound.
And the compressor what is doing
this is analyzing the input.
And if the input is above the
threshold-- we have a threshold
parameter-- it's going to
decide to say, you know,
that's too loud.
I'm going to bring you down.
But if it happens to
be below the threshold,
it's not touched.
So for example, in this
graphic, we choose minus 40.
The input was minus 40 level.
The output will
exactly minus 40.
We are below the threshold.
We are not going to
modify that signal.
But the threshold here
is around minus 25.
So if I choose a
value of minus 20,
the actual output
will be around--
sorry, let's choose an
impulse of minus 10.
Sorry, that's better.
Minus 10 as an input will map
to a minus 20 to the output.
That means that the sound
became softer just because it
was above the threshold.
With all these parameters,
with the compression ratio,
the threshold, and the
input gain, the output gain,
and the other parameters,
we are able to do
what we have been
promising, that we
are able to take sounds
and make them louder,
but take loud sounds
and make them softer.
And that's what a multiband
compressor is doing.
And it's doing this
in different bands.
We can take regions of
frequency from 0 to 1,000 hertz
and behave in a different way
than the region from 1,000
to 5,000 will behave.
We are giving you all
that power to control.
The multiband compressor, being
one of the most complex ones,
you can get these
setters and getters.
So you can get the attack
time, the release time, ratio--
all these parameters that you
need to actually configure
a compressor.
And you do this per band.
As I-- well.
There is one thing, and I'm sure
that everybody is asking this.
Why do you have a
pre-gain, a post-gain,
if your multiband compressor
is before and after
an equalization?
And it's true,
they are redundant.
They are doing pretty
much exactly the same.
But we did that for one reason.
We talked to a lot of
developers and people
that actually have a lot of
these algorithms in real life.
And a big portion
of them, they'd
really like to have an
equalization and then
a multiband compressor
to do some tuning
of their microphones
or the speakers.
Some of them want to have a
multiband compressor and then
an equalization state.
So the easiest way for us to
make this effect very universal
was to build in some redundancy
and do the API in such a way
that they can easily port
older algorithms to this.
The last stage is the limiter.
The limiter is
pretty much the same
that the multiband compressor,
but it's a single band.
So we don't have multiple bands.
And what this is doing
is pretty much the same.
It's taking a sound, and
if it's way too loud--
if it's above a certain
level in the threshold--
it's just going to
squash that down.
It's very useful.
And it's usually found at the
end of any audio processing
chain, especially to
protect the speakers.
You don't want
that the processing
did something funky and
the sound is really loud.
And you don't want
that loud sound
to come out of the speakers.
So you go, and the limiter
is going to say, OK, sorry,
this is too loud.
I'm not going to
clip, but I'm just
going to squash it down so it
doesn't destroy the speakers.
So the limiter is really good.
And I promised to mention
something about the link.
The limiters are link limiters,
and we have the link group.
When we have multiple
channels-- let's
say that we have two channels.
And they are in the same group.
And one of the channels,
the left channel,
something really loud
happen in that channel
and is very, very loud.
It will squish all down
only the left channel.
The stereo image will shift
all the way to the right.
Because this, the
right one, did nothing.
But if they are linked
and, for some reason,
one of the channels got a loud
sound, both will come down
simultaneously and the stereo
signal, the stereo image,
it will not move.
It will stay in the center,
stay where they need it to be.
So being able to control the
link groups in a stereo signal
or in a multichannel
environment--
let's say you want to
link the stereo speakers,
the surround speakers
in a different group,
so you can keep your
spatial image intact.
And that was another feature
that was asked for us to do.
Well, so some more comments
about the dynamics processing
effect.
First one, the
real time controls.
All the controls on the API that
I tried to summarize in here,
but it's really big.
I will encourage you to go on
and read the API documentation.
All these controls, most of
them are real-time controls.
You can use them, and once
that your effect is running,
you can go and change
pretty much any parameter
that you want.
You can change the
levels in here.
You can change the attack,
the release, the ratio--
anything that you want
in any of the channels,
in any of the bands.
You can also use pretty much
the same API for instantiation.
Sometimes you want
to create an effect
and have it ready
to go immediately.
As soon as it
starts playing, it's
playing with all the parameters.
So it will work like that.
We also have some
implementations.
At this moment, we are
offering two implementations,
two variants that we call a
favor frequency favor time.
Sometimes, for these effects,
if you have a frequency domain
implementation, it's
good because you
can have very precise
frequency splits in the bands
that you may need
for your outgoing.
And at the same time, we are
also giving the desired frame
size.
A hint that you can give
to the audio engine--
to the effect engine--
to say, well, you
know, I like frequency
and I would like to have frames
of about 10 milliseconds, 20
milliseconds, for
your processing.
So although it's
not a guarantee,
you can tell the engine,
I would like to do that.
Another important
thing with this effect
is, it's built in into AOSB.
So all AOSB, Android AOSB is
shipping with this effect.
But it's an
OEM-replaceable effect.
So if an OEM really wants
to come with a snappier
effect or a snappier
implementation or something,
they are encouraged to do that.
And if we have OEM
people in the audience,
please talk to me afterwards.
But yes, go ahead and do this.
And the only thing is, please
do very cool effects with these.
Some very good quality effects.
The other thing is, this effect
is available for developers
as an insert effect.
You can go unimplemented
in your applications.
You have a media player.
You have a music application.
You just go and use the
Android media, all the effects,
dynamic processing effects, and
it will be available for you
there in the implementation.
So summary-- today, we
learned a bunch of things.
The first one, we
introduced a new feature,
the sound amplifier.
So it's the new
accessibility feature.
It uses only the smartphone
and a set of headphones
and helps you improve
your listening experience.
Brian showed you a couple
of very cool demos.
And thank you for
the sound people
that they turned off
the AC at that moment
so we could hear things
a little bit better.
We learned about the hearing
threshold and the hearing
threshold shifts and
how they power the way
that the sound amplifier works.
And the last thing, we showed
the dynamics processing effect,
the code, how the stages work,
and how can you go and create
your own dynamics
processing effect
to embed in your
own applications.
So with that, we
want to give thanks
to a lot of people that were
involved in this project--
Brian's team, the Android
accessibility team;
my team, the Android
media framework team;
the research team at Google;
the sound understanding team;
our team in Taipei
that they helped
implement the applications
that you saw today.
And I want to thank
you for staying
so late the last day of
I/O. And please, contact us
if you have any questions.
Thank you.